today we're going to talk about 11 bad
habits that can severely affect your
brain and most of these are going to be
quite surprising in fact the last one
I'm going to talk about is extremely
interesting bad habit number one chronic
exposure to bad news so do you ever hear
any good things in the news it's pretty
much filled with a lot of fear Doom and
Gloom bad news it's all going to end you
need to go in your house go underneath
your bed and hide because our
environment is extremely dangerous to be
in well what do you think that does for
your health well it drops your emotional
state okay if you're at one time happy
and kind of upbeat now you're kind of
grumpy you're kind of in anxiety mode
and you might even be in depression and
there's some interesting data that talks
about your state of being can affect the
structure and the physiology of your
body so you actually lose neurons your
brain actually atrophies so you might
might want to control the exposure the
bad news and it also could be
people giving you bad news too we all
know a certain personality that tends to
not just give us bad news but turn good
news into bad news number two toxic
personalities we have all been into
these relationships which basically
lower our emotional state which would
actually affect the physiology of our
brains so sometimes it's good to get a
long list of all the people that you're
associated with and isolate those who
are a bit toxic and just put them to the
side you want people that bring you up
you want people that support you number
three you are spending way too much time
inside your house or a building it's not
very healthy to be inside all the time
it's extremely therapeutic to be outside
in the fresh air and the sun doesn't
just necessarily give you vitamin D
which is essential for brain health it
gives you infrared now what is infrared
it's a type of spectral energy that can
actually penetrate Your Body by actually
two inches it can actually even go
through your skull and this infrared can
stimulate melatonin the type of
melatonin that's a little bit different
than the Melatonin that's running
through your pituitary it's a type of
melatonin that's in all of your cells
that acts as an antioxidant that is even
more powerful than glutathione it's the
most powerful antioxidant that protects
you against so many things including
stress so inside we have fluorescent
lights poor ventilation we have a lack
of sun and we also have an alteration of
the light in dark Cycles the majority of
the population would greatly benefit by
taking vitamin D before bed especially
if they have problem sleeping especially
if they are inside way too much and
can't get outside so vitamin D is really
important for brain health all right
number four
being on a low-fat low cholesterol diet
now how does that affect the brain well
did you realize that 60 of your brain is
fat here we have this organ that only
makes up two percent of your weight yet
utilizes 20 of all of your energy and
sixty percent of it is fat in fact the
brain is the fattiest organ of all your
organs you need this fat to make myelin
to help the conductivity of the neurons
the information that goes through your
nerve cells travel at a speed of 268
miles per hour it's incredibly fast and
things that lower our fats or
cholesterol like a low-fat diet or
statin drugs can greatly put us at risk
for dementia and a lowered emotional
state whether it's anxiety or even
depression and one really important
point is it takes cholesterol to make
bile salts which actually help you
absorb vitamin A d e
and K so without those fat sample
vitamins as well as the other nutrient
omega-3 fatty acid your brain can
greatly suffer all right number five the
bad habit of being on a high grain diet
the recommendation pretty much given by
all the medical experts you must consume
at least 60 of your diet in the form of
whole grains well there's a problem with
whole grains okay first of all it's not
as nutritious as you might think it's
very high in omega-6 in the book Grain
Brain there's a lot of new information
talking about how grains affect our
brains now when you eat refined grains
you deplete your brain of vitamin B1 and
that can create a huge consequence of
atrophy in your hippocampus the part of
the brain that's involved with memory
and cognitive function number six
consuming a lot of sugar out of all the
things that will destroy your brain
sugar is at the top of the list it's
going to eventually create insulin
resistance and that is going to cause a
starvation of the neurons because when
you have insulin resistance we have the
situation we have this high glucose High
insulin but the resistance doesn't allow
the insulin or glucose to feed the
neurons unless you have ketones floating
around the neurons with starve and you
start having all sorts of
neurodegenerative problems in fact
there's a condition called type 3
diabetes which is Alzheimer's which
occurs from severe insulin resistance
not to mention the high sugar depletes
B1 which creates atrophy of your
hippocampus all right number seven and
this might surprise you too much low
stress if you don't have any stress at
all that can be very unhealthy for your
brain why because you're not exercising
enough you don't have enough physical
activity that is needed to activate
genes for your brain so there's
something called traumatic stress which
basically is a moderate amount of stress
that can cause the body to become
stronger and more resilient and adapt to
a positive State and that would include
the exercise heat therapy cold therapy
hypoxia which is a lack of oxygen
training at a higher altitude so there's
a lot of therapy in a moderate amount of
stress or kind of intermittent doses of
stress and also intermittent fasting is
a form of stress because you're not
feeding your body any food for certain
periods of time can greatly add a
positive stress to allow the brain to
actually grow neurons not enough stress
is just unhealthy as too much stress and
so number eight is high stress if you're
under a chronic high stress mainly
mental stress or you have a lot of
losses or injuries it's very damaging to
the brain because this activates certain
genes in your brain that can turn on
dementia degeneration inflammation and
so high stress High cortisol can create
atrophy of the hippocampus the key part
of the brain that's involved in
cognition okay and also high stress
cortisol depletes you of B1 which also
does the same thing all right number
nine snacking snacking relates to
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting is the antidote to snacking so
many people are snacking even healthy
foods and they're unknowingly creating a
lot of problems with their brain because
in order to strengthen the brain
especially as we age we need to do
things that can help regenerate neurons
I would even venture to say that
snacking is
even worse than eating carbohydrates and
why is that because not only does carbs
increase insulin but eating in general
increases insulin and when you're eating
so frequently you have these little
snacks in the mid-afternoon snack and
the snack before you go to bed what
you're doing is you're jacking up
insulin creating more insulin resistance
and you're going to affect your brain
cells and you're going to find that
that's a really bad habit and the reason
I know that is when a person gives up
snacking
boy do they have a huge positive change
in so many things
including things like getting up in the
middle of night having to urinate these
people that are have frequent urination
really have insulin resistance and the
most simple thing they can do is give up
snacking especially the snacking or
grazing late at night and boom they can
sleep through the whole night and they
just happen to miraculously get rid of
the symptom of frequent urination number
10 anything that decreases the microbes
in your gut directly affect your brain
like antibiotics like glyphosate in the
GMO food which by the way Monsanto got a
patent for glyphosate as being an
antibiotic and unfortunately the earlier
you are exposed to antibiotics in your
life like as a baby
the worse things are but that's a
completely different topic there's a
huge connection between your gut and
your brain whatever happens down here
directly affects here and you do have a
nerve that connects the two and that's
called the vagus nerve one of the side
effects from antibiotics
is dementia not to mention the great
majority of your neurotransmitters okay
many of the B vitamins that are
necessary for brain health are made by
these microbes and number 11 and this is
what you've been waiting for consuming
grain-fed animal products versus the
grass-fed grass finish animal products
now you're saying wait a second where
did you get that Dr Burke well there's
some very interesting data that I want
to share with you I just participated in
a very interesting beef nutrient density
study where we send off our beef from my
farm and they analyze the beef and
compare it to many farms across the
country and what this was was a study
comparing
the grass-fed beef to the grain-fed beef
as far as factors that can contribute to
your health and factors that can
contribute to disease okay so I'm going
to show you this check this out in this
first slide you'll see total
phytochemicals these are phytonutrients
these are plant-based chemicals okay
that are in beef and it just so happens
that the beef that I sent in just
dominated most other even grass-fed
samples which is quite remarkable and
I'm going to share why I think that is
in a minute so stay tuned this is going
to be interesting you can see the grain
fed is very low on the phytonutrients
okay so in general phytonutrients our
antioxidants they have all sorts of
amazing properties they're
anti-inflammatory anti-cancer
etc etc here's another slide that shows
the fatty acid ratio the omega-6 to
omega-3 ratios okay and on average
grass-fed beef would produce a three to
one
that means there's three times as much
omega-6 to omega-3 and the grain fed
beef on average is an eight to one
that's eight times the omega-6 fatty
acid to omega-3 fatty acid well it just
so happens that the beef that I sent in
there had a 1.5
omega-6 to 1 omega-3 and it just so
happens that grain fed meats are high in
omega-6 and so that would increase the
risk of inflammation and by the way
salmon which is high in omega-3 has a
one-to-one ratio of omega-6 to omega-3
and I want to show you a couple other
slides that are very interesting in
relationship to what they found in the
study with our cattle look at vitamin B3
just incredible amounts compared to the
grass-fed as well as the grain fed wow
interesting now I'm going to show you
two other graphs which are very very
interesting in this next graph you'll
see that this value
with Dr Berg's beef is very low okay and
that is because this identifies Advanced
glycation end products this is something
that's very very negative this is
something that contributes to chronic
disease of your brain and the heart this
is what you see in diabetes so what does
this mean it means that if you are
consuming animal products that are
higher in advanced glycation and
products this could contribute to a
worsening of your health and the last
slide is homocysteine now homocysteine
is another biomarker for heart disease
risk check out how low home assisting is
in the sample that I provided as well as
grass-fed then compare that to grain fat
interesting so this is just another
reason why you should consume grass-fed
grass-finished another name for that
would be a hundred percent grass-fed
this is all about the ratios you see
we're trying to get more omega-3 fatty
acids into our brain especially because
out of all the fats 20 is in the form of
Omega-3
DHA and especially the gray matter and
so when you have a high ratio of omega-6
it's competing for the Omega-3
so even though you might be consuming
like cod liver oil or Omega three fatty
acids in your diet if your omega-6 is
too high
it's not going to go in well and so this
is why it's so important to really beef
up no pun intended the omega-3 fatty
acids and this could potentially lower
inflammation in your brain and greatly
support your brain health now here's a
question that you might be wondering
right now why are there so many
phytonutrients in the beef that we have
compared to the typical grass-fed and
that is this the pastures that I raise
my cows on have a much lower ratio of
grass they have a much higher ratio of
weeds that's right and diversity of
weeds I have many different types of
weeds and I have a smaller amount of
grass as compared to a typical pasture
with cattle you're going to have more
grasses and so if you think about it
the more biodiversity that these cows
get to feed on the more different types
of weeds and plants that have their own
microbiome the more Diversified
microbiome they're going to have in
their guts a lot of these phytochemicals
and vitamins are made by the microbiome
and so my theory and I'm going to do
some studies on this to find out for
sure it's the diversity of different
plants that really created this profile
right here which could relate to humans
if you were to have a salad and you had
the same iceberg lettuce every single
day that probably wouldn't be good you
might want to try to increase the range
of types of plants in your diet whether
in your salad or on your plate and there
is some great research on the
relationship between the diversity of
plants and the diversity of your own
microbiome that can greatly help your
health now that being said since we're
on the topic of brain health
if you haven't seen my other video in
the brain you should check it out it's
really cool I'll put it up right here